my group is like Lisa Traeger Megan
Kaylee
um Danny callus Marty DeRosa uh Lane
there's a Marty DeRosa yeah Marty's
really funny can we fight to pay money
to get Joe DeRosa and Marty DeRosa like
in an octagon Marty would win Joe has no
shoulders
that is so funny Keith Robinson always
says like Joe you don't have shoulders
yep no shoulder Joes I think of Keith
every time I pass a sign on the highway
that says no shoulder
you do a great key I'm Keith and I
literally dated during the pandemic the
summer of 2020. I found people we dated
God damn it literally
these are the funniest things to me we
were we almost went to like a second
lockdown and Keith goes off we go on
another lockdown You're Gonna See Me
Dead with a plum up my ass
you were tight with Keith I'm very yeah
one of the funniest people alive him and
me and Joe to Rosa love Joe Liz who
manages at the comedy seller yes we'll
get dinner probably three nights a week
you're living a life I'm gonna like when
I fall asleep I'm just gonna dream that
I'm Mateo a little bit like I'm I'm
having what did I say yesterday I'll
teach you about the bees and the bees
later you'll teach me how it's not even
the gayness I love your gay lifestyle I
love I mean you're the funniest guy in
the world I love that that's like part
of it teaching weird straight guys to
spot wigs yeah but also you're just like
I feel like you're living like a Vespa
lifestyle I do I I I have a very good
life right I like my life I sure hope so
yeah it seems like I said to you last
night we did the live podcast last night
and I was really like I keep looking at
your legs and I don't want you to think
it's inappropriate but like they're
right they're right in my eyeline what's
that take them look at them enjoy they
need to be a little bigger to tell you
the truth but it's it's a disagree I
think there's something I'm kind of like
putting it together I feel a little like
chicken leg but who called you chicken
wings uh this girl named Rachel in high
school got it Rachel finds something no
Rachel Feinstein I'll never forgive her
Rachel doesn't know about legs I
said it right here first Rachel it's
enough of what you said about my legs oh
my God clickbait yeah finally we got
clickbait we got video now we can have
vendettas we'll make it look like a TMZ
article
[Music]
Lanes like uh legs chicken legs